this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through that link
and you not only support this show but
you also get a free premium tank or
aircraft and three days of premium time
as bonus and let's get into it here's
the only person whose baby picture was
flown into space and whose body has been
preserved for decades after his death he
pushed his version of communism so far
and for so long that he was able to
overthrow the government of the largest
country in the world to some he's a hero
to others he is one of the most evil
villains in history in today's by
graphics video we're talking about
Vladimir Lenin the man behind the
Bolshevik Revolution and the founder of
the Soviet Union
the year was 1870 and vladimir Ilyich
Ulyanov was born in a Russian provincial
town called simbirsk he would later grow
up to be known by his alias Vladimir
Lenin and we're going to explain that
later in the video
most revolutionaries they've got this
tragic backstory of a young life of
hardship rising from the lower classes
to demand better treatments for the
downtrodden and many people are taught
that this is the case with Lenin as well
they try to say that his parents were
descended from serfs and that he had to
study hard to break into the middle
class but the truth is that Lenin's
parents they were actually financially
comfortable and by all accounts he had a
happy childhood his mother Maria she was
descended from a wealthy Jewish family
who was Swiss German so she taught him
French and German at home his father
Ilya was the director of public schools
for the entire province they were
considered to be hereditary nobility and
they were far more educated than the
average Russian this placed his parents
in a group called the intelligentsia who
would debate over philosophy and
politics in their spare time many of the
members of the intelligentsia became
politicians who helped shape the new
laws of the nation while others devoted
their life to pushing for a Russian
Revolution Vladimir and his older
brother Alexander they were no exception
his brother loved studying science in
high school but there were no
opportunities to become a scientist in
this small Russian village so Alexander
II moved to some Petersburg to attend
University during this time he joined a
political study group and they began to
discuss the failures of the Romanov
Empire and they believed that the only
way to save Russia would be to remove
them from power when he was 21 years old
Alexander joined a terrorist group who
attempted to assassinate tsar nicholas
ii with a homemade bomb the terrorists
they were caught and alexander and his
friends they were hanged for that crime
vladimir lenin was 17 at the time that
his brother died and he was just about
to graduate from high school even though
he had gone through such a shocking
tragedy he still managed to become the
valedictorian of his graduating class he
went to law school with the intention of
becoming a lawyer but just a few months
into his first semester he joined a
demonstration of students who were
protesting against the school rules soon
as the russian police were already
watching lenin closely to see if he was
also a tear
like his brother the school saw his
participation in these demonstrations as
a sign that he might cause a lot of
trouble in the future so he was expelled
and he decided to educate himself
instead facade Nicholas the seconds he
released the peasant class from this
status meaning that they no longer had
to be indentured servants to wealthy
landowners while this helped relieve the
difficulties of a lot of people it
wasn't really a perfect solution to the
problems that this peasant class were
facing people they were still in debt
and many struggles to just make ends
meet the vast majority of people they
were illiterate and Russia was decades
behind in progress compared to the
Western world many members of the
intelligentsia they were unhappy with
the way things were going and wanted
their country to move forward with
progress just like the rest of the human
race then in he studied law at school
but he realized that with his bad nerves
and his family's bad reputation from his
brother being a terrorist it would be
impossible for him to get a job as a
lawyer Vladimir Lenin he began his self
education by reading Karl Marx and other
revolutionary writers he joined a
Marxist study group where intellectuals
met and discussed philosophy and the
possibility of a Russian Revolution it
was around this time that a major famine
spread throughout the lands near his
home records of the 1891 famine they
vary drastically in some say that there
were 300,000 deaths while others say it
was closer to five million people Lenin
he was fine of course his family they
were well-off and he had plenty of money
to buy food but he also did nothing to
aid the people who were dying around him
he was actually kind of happy about this
saying that the worse things got in
Russia the better it would ultimately
become he knew that people needed to
start dying in the thousands before
people would be angry enough to want a
revolution Karl Marx wrote that he
believed an industrialized society would
be the most likely to create a
revolution because he believes that
they'd want to rise up against
commercialism Vladimir Lenin rewrote a
lot of what Marx was actually saying
Lenin wrote the idea that the
revolutionary intelligentsia will guide
the uneducated peasants even though the
philosophy was labeled as Marxism all
throughout the reign of the Soviet Union
it is now call
Leninism because it really was his own
personal ideas and not those of Karl
Marx Lenin joined a socialist group that
gained access to a factory there they
started handing out flyers to factory
workers they were trying to make people
angry about their work situations and
wanted them to demand shorter hours and
higher pay they were caught though
because they accidentally left a police
informant during the group and they were
all arrested at this time any form of
revolutionary activity was taken very
seriously and they all had to serve jail
time he was 26 years old at the time he
went to prison but it was nothing like
what would imagine a Russian prison to
be since he was descended from a noble
bloodline he was given a very
comfortable place to live where he could
wear whatever clothes he wanted as well
as read books and he also received daily
visits from his family and friends he
was even allowed to continue writing his
revolutionary pamphlets and essays while
he was behind bars for that very
activity after just 14 months in jail he
was exiled to Siberia for three more yes
in a way though this was actually a good
move for him and he was given a
government pension that covered his
living expenses this meant he spent most
of his time reading and writing about
the revolution which is what he would be
doing anyway so for him this time in
Siberia was more like a very long
writers retreat and he was actually very
productive during his time away
indeed his girlfriend was also arrested
and sent to Siberia as well they got
married there so that they could live in
exile together so I've got him in Lenin
he's writing these revolutionary ideas
in Siberia and he's sending them back to
his socialist friends who were
publishing his essays in a secret
newspaper he made up a variety of
different pen names so that it seemed
like multiple intellectuals were all
pushing for the same revolution but
really it was just him the pen name he
eventually stuck with was Vladimir Lenin
which is what he is remembered as today
after being released from his time in
exile he was 30 years old and he and his
wife moved to Munich Germany where they
could print revolutionary newspapers in
Russian without getting into trouble
with the German police he would then
have the papers smuggled into Russia
with the help of fellow revolutionaries
who carried them in their luggage one of
these co-conspirators was a young man
named Joseph Stalin who was equally
passionate about the coming revolution
and would eventually take Lenin's place
now just before we get into the next
part of Lenin's life
I do wanna mention today
sponser war thunder war thunder is a
realistic free-to-play vehicle combat
game and I know that the advert in the
middle of the video is not ideal but we
can't do subjects like this without
sponsors this video has themes that you
to advertisers just don't really like so
without a sponsor we can't really pay
for it so thank you for watching this
now this one sir it's also free it's
also a game so that's also pretty great
now it always amazes me when I hear that
there are millions of players of these
online games millions so there's a lot
of people but then I can see why it's
amazing what games can do these days
especially free games it's free to play
it looks incredible just look at the
footage we're showing here I mean why
not in this game there are over 1200
historically accurate vehicles there are
tanks aircraft ships incredible vehicles
from the 1930s onwards so this game is
available on PC ps4 and Xbox one so join
us on the battlefield for free using the
link below doing that supports this show
and it also you guys see a free premium
tank or aircraft and three days of
premium time as a bonus for registering
[Music]
and most tellings of the Russian
Revolution Vladimir Lenin's rise to
power always seems very straightforward
he is always depicted as a well
respected intellectual who was able to
rise to power almost immediately but
that's pretty far from the truth his
revolution it was a long process but he
never gave up trying to slither his way
into a place of power Vladimir Lenin he
had a real talent for stirring up
trouble even among the intelligentsia he
would call anyone who disagreed with him
his enemies since the sniveling
bourgeoisie even though they were all
middle class socialists he had
absolutely no patience for anyone who
did not agree with him a hundred percent
during one of their meetings to discuss
their strategies about the revolution he
insulted some of the socialists so
strongly that they got up and left while
they were gone he declared that his
ideals were the Bolsheviks or the
majority while everyone else was the
Menshevik or minority party the name
Bolshevik it stuck from that point on
so in 1904 Lenin he gets a bit stressed
out from all of this debating and
discussing his philosophy as well as
handing out pamphlets and stuff like
that and he got rather ill he decided to
take it me along hiking holiday in the
Swiss Alps with his wife but the
Bolsheviks they continued their own
revolutionary work while he was gone in
1905 there was a peaceful protest in
some Petersburg in front of the Winter
Palace people held up signs pleading for
better working conditions all they
wanted was an eight-hour workday they
even saying god save the Tsar to show
their love and support for the royal
family but instead of listening to their
requests our nicholas ii ordered his
guards to shoot at the crowd thousands
of people died and it became known as
Bloody Sunday people they were outraged
in the began protesting for workers
rights all across Russia when Lenin
heard the news he abruptly ended his
vacation in Switzerland and decided to
come back to Russia he finally had the
opportunity that had been waiting for he
began to preach to people that they
needed to organize and take action
against the Tsar he got a little too
excited about the idea of a bloody
revolution and wrote how they should
pour hot acid onto the Royal Guard and
got into specific details of how to
murder someone which was something that
no other revolutionary writer had done
before however there was still not
enough revolutionaries willing to fight
and kill people on Lenin's behalf many
of the Bolshevik revolutionaries they
were exiled to Siberia
and Lenin fled to Switzerland before he
could be arrested too then World War one
rolls around and that basically puts a
damper on everyone's revolutionary plans
Tsar Nicholas the second he left some
Petersburg to join his men on the front
lines the thaw also left his wife
Alexandra in the care of their spiritual
adviser grigori rasputin this man
believed that he was the second coming
of Christ didn't believe that he had
magical healing powers given to him by
God many of the decisions that Rasputin
made were harshly criticized like
putting his unqualified friends in
powerful positions if you want to learn
more about Rasputin by the way we did a
video about him find a link to that
below lenin still continued to write
about his revolutionary ideas from
Switzerland's and encouraged soldiers to
turn their guns against their officers
during the war
well ours almost no one was actually
reading the underground newspapers
except for the handful of active
Bolsheviks the vast majority of the
Russian people were eager to defend
their country but the war it was still a
disaster millions of people died the
flesh and ruined Russia's economy and
women were standing in long red lines
tsar nicholas ii renamed sent Petersburg
to Petrograd as a symbol of his devotion
to the Russian people for years people
had criticized the name sent Petersburg
because it sounded too German and
Petrograd was much more Russian sounding
Tsar Nicholas believed that this would
somehow prove his loyalty but the
gesture it just wasn't enough for the
first time thousands of Russian people
were trained in the military and they
knew how to use guns soldiers and police
officers were just as angry as the rest
and people were swarming the palace to
take over from the Tsar all on their own
Lenin well he had nothing to do with it
he wasn't even there he was still in
Switzerland and he was panicking because
the Revolution it was starting without
him the political parties were split
into two groups the provisional
government which was made up of the
representatives called the Duma and the
workers Soviets who were controlled by
the trade unions and made up of the
peasants soldiers and factory workers
Lenin knew that he was no match for the
provisional government's leader
Alexander Kerensky
he was a seasoned lawyer and a master of
public speaking Kerensky resonated with
the tumor and since Lenin was not
actually a lawyer he knew that he would
lose in a political debate against him
so therefore Lenin focused his efforts
on trying to manipulate the lesser
educated workers Soviets in
stet when he arrived at the train
station Lenin's friends were there to
greet him and he hardly said hello
before standing on a pedestal to shout
at the crowds that they had done an
awful job with a revolution and that it
wasn't going to be over until they took
down the provisional government almost
no one actually agreed with them and
they just carried on going about their
business even his fellow Bolsheviks no
longer wanted to print his essays
because it was such an unpopular opinion
the provisional government was leading
Russia back to war against Germany in
World War one it was still going on but
soldiers they were not happy to serve it
was the reason why they had overthrowing
the Tsar in the first place people
wanted the war to be over any of them
abandoned their posts on the battlefield
or completely refused to go in the first
place
Lenin heap tried to stand up again and
lead these crowds of peasants but
someone from the provisional government
shouted that he was a German spy this
made the crowd turn against Timmons he
had to run away Alexander Kerensky could
see that he was going to cause a lot of
trouble for the authority of the
provisional government so he outlawed
the existence of the Bolshevik Party
Lenin at this point he needed to escape
he bit on a bad wig shaved his beard and
got on the next train to Finland
Vladimir Lenin he spent a very long time
hiding on a Finnish farm continuing to
write his ideas and send them back to
Russia since no one was actually
listening to him or agreeing with his
ideas he decided to take Russia by force
one night in October of 1917 he snuck
back into Russia and met up with his
comrades in Petrograd by this time he
had convinced more members of the
Workers Party to join his side he
convinced his Bolshevik followers of the
Red Guards to break into the Winter
Palace for a coup d'etat they captured
members of the provisional government at
gunpoint the Duma they were arrested
taken to jail and Vladimir Lenin became
the new leader of Russia without ever
being voted in
[Music]
Vladimir Lenin addressed the crowd of
Russian peasants that morning after
storming the Winter Palace and
introduced himself as their new dictator
and the leader of the Soviet Union
Lenin promised them exactly what they
wanted and he did it in these simplest
words possible peace bread and land one
of his first acts as leader was to Benz
the war with Germany people were happy
because that's exactly what they wanted
all along right from the beginning he
isolated himself at the Kremlin in
Moscow so that he could continue writing
the Bolshevik Party they wasted no time
in spreading propaganda that Vladimir
Lenin was like a kind old grandfather
who only wanted the best for the Russian
people and that they didn't have to
worry about anything anymore everything
was gonna be fine old granddaddy Lenin
was gonna take care of you in reality
though he was blood thirsty and he
wanted his revolution to be as violent
as possible
he told tenants to kill their landlords
and encouraged violence against the
upper classes he gave out the order to
his Red Guard to remove the Romanov
royal family from their palace at that
time the number of men who joined in
Lenin's Red Guard had grown to 200,000
and he had a small army to stand behind
him many of the Russian people they
protested because they loved the
Romanovs especially the young children
at first Lenin lied saying that they
would be kept somewhere safe but once he
realized that they were too much of a
threat to his power he ordered their
execution since the family was being
held in Siberia it took a very long time
for the public to learn about their
deaths at first people believed there
was just saw Nicholas who was killed and
that the women and children was spared
it would take years for the public to
learn the truth of his brutality he
proclaims that every Russian citizen
should have good rations but in order to
do that the farms would have to be
controlled by the government
farmers were not allowed to keep or sell
the food they grew and all of the crops
were spread out among the entire nation
people could no longer choose their jobs
and were given employments in newly
constructed factories based on the needs
of the country now some people were
happy about this and it gave them a
sense of security
indeed statues of Lenin were erected
around Petrograd and many people called
him a hero now another real always
drinking Lenin's kool-aid though plenty
of people were furious with him for
ordering the death of the innocent
Romanov children in 1918 a woman named
Vanya Kaplan attempted to assassin
Lenin she shot him twice at close range
now him seriously injured but he still
managed to survive Kaplan was arrested
and she refused to give up the name of
any of her co-conspirators she was
executed in September of that same year
then it would recover from his injuries
in the hospital but from that day
forward he showed no mercy to anyone who
expressed even the smallest opposition
to his rule even though he always
encouraged the peasant class to stand up
for their rights and rebel against their
government it was no longer okay to do
so once that was his government any time
peasants or farmers tried to protest
against his new rules they were killed
without mercy those who opposed Lenin
didn't go down without a fight though
in 1918 a group called the white army
battled against the Red Army in a civil
war fighting to take down the Soviet
Union however the white army was not
organized very well and they lost the
war in 1920 farmers were angry that
their grain was being stolen from them
for the greater good of the communist
nation this began what is known as the
Tambov rebellion but they were all
gassed by the Red Army and their crops
were taken away from their dead hands at
least 50,000 people were interned mostly
women children and the elderly
some of them sent to camps as hostages
there were several other incidents like
this and any rebellion among the Russian
people it was quickly squashed even
after trying to make his political
philosophy work through threats of death
and destruction
Lenin knew when to call it quits when
millions of people were on the brink of
dying from drought and famine he decided
to temporarily stop communism and
allowed farmers to keep the food that
they planted and sell the excess food
for profit you know that's something
called capitalism unsurprisingly this
was a huge success people were no longer
starving and the economy improved once
things had stabilized again Lennie went
back to forcing food rations
unfortunately not every leader who
followed in Lenin's footsteps knew when
to take a break from communism during a
time of famine Lenin's successor Josef
Stalin would be remembered as one of the
worst dictators who ever lived for this
very reason
when he was in his 50s Vladimir Lenin's
health began to decline and he had
multiple strokes but even when he was in
poor health he was trying to write in
his journal to give commands from his
bed when he died in 1924 people were
shocked as they were not expecting him
to die so young hundreds of thousands of
people showed up to his funeral
even those below freezing temperatures
people were sobbing upset that the one
man who truly cared about them was gone
he did manage to make some improvements
in the economy and there was so much Pro
Lenin propaganda that had been
circulated that people believed that he
truly was their Savior five days after
Lenin passed away the city of Petrograd
was renamed Leningrad in his honor his
body was embalmed so that people could
continue to visit him and pay their
respects Vladimir Lenin's reputation it
only became more powerful after his
death he was like a legend who managed
to change not just Russia but several
other countries throughout the world
communist leaders looked to him for
inspiration on how to run their own
dictatorships the USSR and continued for
decades after his death and despite all
of its setbacks the system led to more
progress than Russia had seen in
hundreds of years before Lenin the
country was very far behind the rest of
the Western world in terms of
industrialization education and
modernization if it were not for all of
the reforms made by the Soviet Union
they may have never gotten so far with
the space race against the United States
and they still might be lagging behind
today in 1991 the Soviet Union it
collapsed and all of the statues of
Lenin they were torn down instead of
seeing him as a hero he is now
remembered as a villain Leningrad
became st. Petersburg once again there
is no telling how far the nation would
have progressed if it were not for the
creation of the Soviet Union but one
thing is for sure without Vladimir Lenin
the world would be a very different
place today so I really hope you enjoyed
that video if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe also if you're looking for
something else from me why not check out
my other channel called today I found
out we do daily fact videos you'll find
that links to below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]